facebook gründer mark zuckerberg hat
elon musk angeworfen es geht um unser
letztes video ihnen macht waren ja vor
den gefahren von künstlicher
intelligenz kurs ki und da findet mark
zuckerberg gar nicht so gut denn macht
fordert regulierung für savas ein graus
wenn er will mit facebook gerade den
rückstand bei ki auf eine baldige
regulierung können sie ihnen da einen
strich durch die rechnung machen jetzt
den blick vom science fiction herzlich
willkommen
jetzt geht es zur sache markt wasserburg
fossilen musk freie entwicklung von
künstlicher intelligenz bertels
kontrolle und regulierung es geht um die
gefahren die von ki ausgehen ob sie
existieren oder ob sie nur in gespinsten
den letzten video hatten wir ja darüber
berichtet maske waren eindringlich vor
ki und durch die straßen marodierenden
robotern die alles töten was sich ihnen
in den weg stellt künstliche
intelligenz ist ein fundamentales risiko
für die existenz der menschlichen
zivilisation so wie es autounfälle
flugzeugabsturz zu drogen oder
schlechtes essen nie sein werden ich
habe zugang zu modernsten künstliche
intelligenz die es gibt und ich glaube
die leute sollten besorgt darüber sein
so machte in einem interview auf der
national governors versammlung in den
usa za camberg wirft ihn jetzt vor
negativ und damit verantwortungslos zu
sein
er ist jedenfalls optimistisch in sachen
kann er leute die diese
weltuntergangsszenarien beschwören
nicht verstehen ein frontalangriff auf
markt und auch die bemühungen bei ki
sehr vorsichtig zu sein und die gefahren
stets im auge zu behalten macht konter
der augenblicklich und ließ auf twitter
verlauten und gibt ebenso eine breite
auswahl comeback ab er habe mit
zuckerberg gesprochen und ein sehr
eingeschränktes verständnis der
materie festgestellt mit anderen worten
zuckerberg hat keine ahnung sollte das
allerdings zutreffen wäre es
gefährlich den wasserburgs arbeitet
intensiv an der entwicklung von ki bei
facebook hat er ein team aus
internationalen spitzenkräften
zusammengestellt und google vorsprung
aufzuholen und wer wie doppelt zum einen
hat die google-tochter sieht meint mit
der künstlichen intelligenz avantgarde
den besten spieler der welt geschlagen
zum anderen hat google mit google brain
ein neuronales netz mit die burning
entwickelt das zum beispiel seit letztem
jahr den youtube algorithmus selbst
programmiert das macht google grant
täglich und das für jeden nutzer
individuell jeden tag empfiehlt google
brain jedem nutzer individuell videos
dafür wird die bosch und surgery
durchsucht und mit anderen nutzern
abgeglichen bei übereinstimmung werden
videos empfohlen
die anderen nutzer mit ähnlichen
interessen gefallen jeden tag wird
google brainbows schlauer und findet
immer besser videos dies empfehlen kann
schon heute sind wir also von k
abhängig und wie entscheidet für uns
welche videos und als nächstes
empfohlen werden vielleicht siehst du
dieses video auch gerade weil es google
brain für dich ausgesucht hat schon ein
bisschen gespenstisch was noch
gespenstischer ist ki übernimmt auch
die schlechten eigenschaften von nutzern
so ist sie rassistisch wie in einer
forschungsarbeit der künstlich
university in den usa festgestellt wurde
wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen
auf den studienleiter einigen khalid
khan hatten herausgefunden dass die
künstliche intelligenz an gewohnheiten
von menschen übernimmt künftig
ergänzt wird ja in form von programm
mit unendlich viel daten gefüttert und
dazu gehören auch eine unmenge an
texten so lernt die software sowie
anhand von texten wörter und wächst
sie in beziehung zueinander irgendwann
weitere beispiel dass mann und frau
in welchem verhältnis zueinander stehen
die youtuber und youtube
das problem am bibeltexten ist dass sie
von menschen geschrieben wurden und die
haben vorurteile
das forscherteam hat jetzt das gelernte
von globi überprüfen es dabei darauf
gestoßen dass die software so auch
vorurteile übernommen hatte typische
vornamen von afrika aus afroamerikanern
waren für die software eher unangenehm
und typischerweise eher angenehm die
software hatte alle vorurteile aus den
eingespeisten texten übernommen also
schon jetzt schnell ki eine wirkliche
gefahr zahl noch ganz anders macht es
befürchtet aber es zeigt dass die
wirklich kontrolliert werden muss
zuckerberg ist hier wirklich etwas sagen
wir optimistisch wieder streit weiter
geht darüber halte ich euch hierbei
ging natürlich auf dem laufenden wenn
er kein videos zum thema und auch zu
allen anderen themen verpassen wollt
dann wird mir hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergesst nicht den genau auf wie locker
hier geht es weiter mit künstliche
intelligenz ist menschlich da geht es um
rassistische ki und was die forscher und
forscherinnen genau herausgefunden haben
dass wirklich etwas erschreckend also
unbedingt anschauen also drauf klicken
und ansonsten bis dann bleib dran